several places are still far far away
from ending their epidemics and in fact
are seeing their epidemics increase and
that's what I'm focusing on asking the
question why and who's there on the
ground trying to fix things my name is
John Cohen I'm a staff writer with
science magazine the Pulitzer Center
funded travel for this project which
also involved the collaboration with the
PBS Newshour
I've been covering the epidemic around
the world now for nearly thirty years
when I began doing this I go on trips to
other countries and see warehouses full
of people dying I don't see that now but
I do see places that are struggling to
use the very powerful tools that exist
both to help keep people alive and to
stop them from spreading the virus to
other people about one out of four
mother-to-child transmissions in the
world happen in Nigeria and Nigeria has
had billions of dollars of foreign aid
poured into the country to help solve
the problem so what's wrong
the big problem is so many pregnant
women never intersect with health care
they either give birth at home or they
have a traditional birth attendants but
she's not necessarily a trained health
care professionals who's gonna do HIV
testing so one of the creative things
that night Nigeria has going right now
is a project working with traditional
birth attendants I met with the
traditional birth attendant mama Mehta
and they have trained mama Mehta to
encourage women to come to her clinic on
a day when an HIV testing group shows up
and she also knows that if a woman does
test positive that she should transfer
her to a hospital or a regular clinic
for care so that's one of the
progressive things that's happening in
Nigeria to try to really isolate a
problem about 90% of Nigerians go to
services on the weekends whether they're
Christian or Muslim in the countries
about 50/50 so a project has begun
called baby shower where they go to the
churches and they have the priests say
all pregnant
their partners come to the front for a
special blessing and then the priest
does after the service we're gonna have
health testing here we're gonna check
you for sickle-cell anemia and we're
gonna check you for hepatitis B and
we're gonna check you for HIV HIV has
just wrapped up into this because
there's so much stigma and
discrimination people might not come for
an HIV test but for a health test with
all these things they'll show up and
they get a gift for their baby and for
their birthing and then if a woman test
positive there they link the woman to
care and they make sure that she gets on
antiretroviral drugs her baby receives
the treatment to stop transmission and
it's a full package to try to address
the problem we publish our score this is
some amazing results it's priced like a
zoom you can sprays here somebody else
hmm so what is that and comes looking
for what it is what they getting to the
village you see us running I call me
know the baby shower I saw you today
Donna the perfume is spreading the
fragments are in everywhere Russia
accounts for 80% of all the new
infections over the past five years in
Eastern Europe and Central Asia and it
has about 10% new infections a year
something's really wrong well what
what's broken
well Russia only has antiretroviral
drugs reaching about one third of the
infected people that's a big problem
they do not promote needle exchange
programs they barely allow them so the
Russian epidemic has just been growing
at a time when it's dropping everywhere
else in Europe in that harsh political
environment HIV infected people and
advocates have created a pharmacy sort
of an underground pharmacy to supply
infected people with drugs when the
government runs out of drugs so they
collect these antiretroviral drugs and
redistribute them to people in need this
is for free
just help each other when I did a just
completely unbiased look at the data
what's happening in the United States
Miami has more new infections than any
city in the country that shocked me and
then when I looked at the top 10 cities
in the country four of them were in
Florida for the new infection rate
Florida has basically every driver of
the epidemic that we know of in the
United States high rate of infection and
men who have sex with men it has people
who inject drugs public transportation
isn't really what it should be and then
our rural areas are even more challenged
homelessness mental health ethnic
disparities all get in the way of us
dealing with the epidemic here it's a
challenge under the best of
circumstances to get appropriate
messaging to get people into care the
Haitian community for example a lot of
people don't speak English they speak
Creole so to reach the Haitian community
a radio program has a health section
that just goes after that Creole
population and it's a way to
specifically get them HIV tested here's
a clinic in Little Haiti that has people
speaking Creole they'll pick you up at
your home and take you back and forth we
know if you are treated with
antiretroviral drugs and you drive your
virus in your body down the levels that
are undetectable your odds of
transmitting that virus to someone else
are exceedingly low myself I've taken my
lips all the time so I have become
undetectable that's at the heart of all
these efforts is get everyone tested get
everyone who's positive on treatments
and getting everyone who is at high risk
to lower their risk to do something like
needle and syringe exchange programs or
pre exposure prophylaxis which is a pill
usually is to treat HIV that can prevent
HIV that's what's needed to really break
the back of the epidemic
and there's a whole lot we can do
you
[Music]